your
father died in 2017
your mother died in 2019.
do you miss them very much so
is there a memory uh that
fond memory that stands out or maybe
what have you learned from them
from my mother i mean she was very much
my inspiration for pursuing intellectual
work because
she studied at the university and then
because of the
second world war after the second world
war she was
born in bulgaria they they immigrated to
to israel
and and she left
university to work on a farm and
later in life when all the kids left
home she
went back to the university and finished
the phd but she planted
in me the intellectual curiosity and
valuing learning as
or acquiring knowledge as a very
important
element in life and
and my uh love with philosophy came from
attending classes that she took at the
university
uh when i was a teenager um
i was fortunate to go to some of these
and
they inspired me later on and i'm very
different
than my colleagues as you can tell
because my upbringing was quite
different and
the only reason i'm doing physics or
astrophysics is because of circumstances
i
uh at age 18 i was asked to serve in the
military
and the only way for me to pursue
intellectual
work was to work on
physics because that was the closest to
philosophy
and i was good at physics so they
admitted me to an elite program called
telpeot that
allowed me to finish my phd at age
24 and to actually propose the first
international project that was funded by
the star wars initiative
from ronald reagan and that broad meat
brought me to the u.s to visit
washington dc where we were funded from
and then on one of the visits i went to
the institute for advanced study at
princeton and
met john bakal that later offered me a
five-year fellowship there
under the condition that i'll switch to
astrophysics at which point
you know i said okay i cannot give up on
this opportunity i'll do it
switch to astrophysics it felt like a
forced
marriage kind of arranged mary yes and
then i was offered the position at
harvard because nobody wanted that uh
they first elected someone else and that
someone said i don't want to become
a junior faculty at the harvard
astronomy department because the chance
for being promoted
are very small so he took another job
and then
i was taken in line they gave it to me i
didn't care much because i could go back
to the farm any day
and after three years i was tenured yes
and
eventually a decade later became the
chair of this department
and served for nine years as the chair
of the astronomy department
at harvard but at that point it became
clear to me that i'm actually married
to the love of my life even though it
was an arranged marriage
there are many philosophical questions
in astrophysics that we can address
but i'm still very different than my
colleagues you know that
were focusing on technical skills in
getting to this job so my mother was
really
extremely instrumental in in planting
the seeds of stuff thinking about the
big picture
uh in me then my father he was
you know he was working in the farm and
we didn't speak much because we sort of
understood each other without speaking
but what he uh
gave me is a sense of
uh you know that it's more important to
do things than to talk about them
i love the the the i mean my apologies
but mit
mind and hand i love that there's uh
that the root of philosophy that you
gain from
your mom and uh the the hand that action
is all that ultimately in the end
matters
you